hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Samantha
Ashley Phil we're gonna watch the second
trailer for American sniper the Clint
Eastwood film okay
stars Bradley Cooper okay based on the
true story about sniper okay yes I have
heard about this I saw the first trailer
and everyone told me a bunch of
information about the true story and
then I was just even reading today how
they were like you know you really
should have done your research before
watching this trailer and then I was
like okay second trailer here we go
I don't remember a single [ __ ] thing
I learned about this movie research it's
about the film okay I'm supposed to
accept it on its own merits let me ask
you a question Chris would you be
surprised if I told you that the Navy
has credited you with over 160 kills
[Music]
you ever think that you might have seen
things or done some things over there
that you wish you had oh that's not me
[Music]
thank you
they'll tell you enough I'm so proud of
you
you're such a great father
so you're not worrying about what might
happen
[Music]
I'm willing to meet my Creator
the answer every shot that I took
come pick it up
[Music]
well stateside your home what what are
you doing I guess I just need a little
bit
[Music]
[Music]
thing that parts near all the guys that
I couldn't say
[Music]
please
[Music]
ready
[Music]
I'm ready to come home well theatres on
Christmas
that is exactly what I want to watch on
Christmas yeah are they releasing this
on Christmas
oh Jesus oh Jesus yeah
wow so much to say from just the trailer
has Oscar bait written all over it
shut up were filming I wanted to see
this movie from the beginning just
because of Bradley Cooper this looks
like one of the best performances he's
done and I mean he's had some stellar
ones but oh my god
I know his performance of wedding
crashers really blew me away wheat and
as Hannibal in the a-team that is really
where Bradley Cooper's true acting
credits belong and his supporting
rolling yes man as Jim Carrey's best
friend oh really what I know is
filmography but this looks okay no but
his performance in this looks like
[ __ ] fantastic
he just seems like to embody roles now
when he actually makes these movies he
was always great but now he's like just
he is one of the actors now it's like
every rule he just builds and builds and
builds like he's in hit and I heard
there was silver lining and Marion
hustle and all that Clint Eastwood he he
he needs a powerhouse film again because
it's been a few consistent films where
they haven't been the greatest so we
need a nice one movie like this again
and to see that there's like respectable
film critics like Leonard Maltin and
Rolling Stones some respectable dudes
are like that is a fantastic movie it
does instill a lot of confidence you
know I like a minute I like to cry
I like crying it's gonna be a bit of a
tearjerker and it looks real they have
captured the reality and the hardships
of a situation the guy at that's at war
and you know gets probably PTSD and has
a family and it's rough and the
decisions that he has to make out there
hole that kid I was really
I'm not liking movie but this really got
you thinking it really got me really got
you thinking I feel that's a powerful
trailer I'm gonna be a mess and I watch
the music biryani just literally
reviewed the whole film and all you saw
was the drink I know you're like this
movie puts you in a whirl
don't be around I'm gonna have a botched
box of tissues and probably some
chocolate ice cream I don't want to sit
next to you while you know I'm not gonna
watch home theaters I'm gonna be there
right after Sunday mess or whatever
Christmas is Thursday Thursday do
Chinese people have any questions yeah
they do it's New Year's that's different
there's New Year's then there's Chinese
New Year right glad we got totally
relevant I am a little worried that
Clint Eastwood is gonna get snubbed
though even if this is really good
because you haven't seen the movie
really saying he should win no I knew
haven't even when I do watch it if there
is the potential that like I would want
him to win I don't know there's been
times that I wanted him no one and he
just politic
he already has a few Oscars he doesn't
anymore Clint Eastwood okay okay I think
we should give it to Peter and Bobby
Farrelly for dumb and dumber - that's
what I think yeah absolutely gaining
some weight for this movie was there
listen the ways I mean Bradley he was
actually doing he was actually doing
deadlifts they weren't harm curls oh my
god I know these things
hi Bradley I see you yeah you'd like him
to go Cooper and your anal sex we
brought it back people anyway guys if
you're gonna do the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects check out
some Mathis channel and
yeah there's gonna be more videos coming
soon I have some surprises underway in
the next few weeks so she does she does
some fun adventures should make you
laugh you should do a cooper pooper
video it sounds like a pooper scooper
video here she was not like it's joke
[Applause]
Brian Wilson hey excuse me for a woman
nothing much to say here because I've
only known of your channel and videos
for about two months
can I get a shout out anyways keep up
the dick and fart jokes actually I don't
make them any fart jokes I didn't make a
poop joke today but fart jokes are not
really my thing
I don't like farting well I like party
when I'm by myself I don't even like
talking about farting it's you only
mystery for you you just have to talk
about [ __ ] on girls anyway Brian
Wilson dude I don't care that you've
only known about for two months that's
[ __ ] awesome
you're you're the [ __ ] you're the [ __ ]
thanks for watching and take a [ __ ]
girls don't leave no riot sometimes no
don't look very helding started watching
your reaction videos a few weeks back
minions was the trailer watch the whole
bunch since and a couple of real rejects
marathons yeah can i have a shout out
please cheers happy Christmas and New
Year's to all the team from Australia PS
Sam is cute talking about you talking
about you he wants this [ __ ] on you Gary
good for you thank you thank you for
watching and I'm glad you liked the
minions trailer and that's awesome that
you've done real rejects marathons cuz
that is the [ __ ] yeah the [ __ ]
thank you bringing it back to the [ __ ]
anyone that does that I'm just going
along with it I'm looking at Gary's uh
profile
right now he looks like what Michael
Douglas could have turned into if he was
a biker he does like badass or this
penguins he looks like he knows are the
Madagascar finger the are penguins
why is he really a guard he was instead
of Madagascar now he's into the minions
I don't know it just seems a little
creepy sometimes you just seem a little
creepy that is true you have no right to
judge I don't
Jesus said don't try and even quote it
no don't quote Jesus the Golden Rule
treat others as you'd want people to
treat you
BAM Jesus to you Merry Christmas and a
Happy New Year